bon alors à lemon je te ferai pas le
l'affront de leur parler des césars
parce qu'il est temps par les 170 voix
du client
ouais c'est ça c'est par mois napperons
après que ouais ouais franc parler
d'autre chose alors puisse donc pas la
silhouette césar s'appelle christian
roth et olivier gasnier que la crise a
rencontré après un grand flic une
dépression j'ai commencé il ya
maintenant à les rencontrer
quand on a qu'une paire semble avignon
et puis je les ai revus un moment où
effectivement se demander tout et vous
aurez des salaires bien qu'une femme
d'affaires du 2 ème du mois et
et alors pourquoi vous devez y est
accusée de jouer avec nous et nous avons
pourtant j'ai une vedette de tous je
m'endette ouais ouais et bien joué dans
l'autre course et c'est la télé ça
commence à écouter ça commence bien et
celle où c'est le premier nom c'est
terrible ça passe de 10,1 pas ne vais
pas vous mais là c'est moins serrés que
ça peut être que il est clair que les
séries qu'elle s'était passé qu'elle est
grand je veux ça existe en le montre
l'histoire est alors en fait pas une
déception c'est lors d'un dîner part à
9,6 pour aller jusqu'au bout de la
relation du couple était enfant comment
ils vont 3
alexandre à l'épaule je me suis trompé
j'ai style peu diplomatique
j'ai pas le temps d'aller ensemble je
vous l'avais fait pas rêver
voilà le danger de faire un
questionnaire d'enfer spécial pour toi
un stage